Now, I'm gonna take a moment later tonight and the days ahead...
...to fully absorb the history we've made here.
But what I care about most is the history our country has yet to write.
Our children and grandchildren will look back at this time,...
...at the choices we are about to make,...
...the goals we will strive for, the principles we will live by.
And we need to make sure that they can be proud of us.
The end of the primaries is only the beginning of the work we're called to do.
But if we stand together, we will rise together because we are stronger together!
Let's go out and make that case to America!
Thank you!
God bless you all and God bless America!